wenn Euch auch gerade viel zu heiß ist
dann probiert dieses instant Mango
Sorbet und wir brauchen dafür nur vier
Zutaten und zwar Mango als Hauptzutat
Ahornsirup kokosjoghurt und eine Limette
die halbiere ich und Presse Sie in
unseren Standmixer wichtig ist dass wir
die flüssigen Zutaten zuerst eingeben um
die Klingen von unserem Mixer zu
schützen weil wenn man nur gefrorene
Früchte reinhaut geht das ziemlich
schnell kaputt kokosjoghurt und
Ahornsirup für die süße jetzt fehlt nur
noch die gefrorene Mango nicht alles auf
einmal dann mixt sich besser und Vollgas
das sieht schon gut aus wir geben die
restliche Mango dazu kann sehr gut sein
dass sie ein bisschen nachhelfen müsst
und fertig ist unser Mango Sorbet und es
ist noch gefroren hoffe ich zumindest
machen wir so eine Nocke und fertig ist
das gute Stück wenn ich ein bisschen
weniger weich haben wollt gibt's noch
mal für eine halbe Stunde im
Gefrierschrank aber ich finde das hier
ist eine der besten Sachen die man
aktuell machen kann